The correct answer is 15. We know, from the Pythagorean Theorem, that the sum of
the squares of either of the shorter sides of the triangle is equal the square
of the hypotenuse. So, in the case of this triangle, that means that we have 9
squared plus 12 squared equals something squared. We want to find out what c is.
Simplifying the left side of our equation gives us 225 equals c squared. Now
it's really easy at this point to think, oh my gosh, I found our answer. But
remember, we're not looking for c squared, we're looking for just c on its own.
We just want the length of this side, not its square. So how do we handle this?
How do I get rid of this exponent of 2? Well, we need to talk a little bit more
about exponents, so we can figure out how to deal with this. What we need to do
is to take the square root of both sides. You've probably worked with square
roots before and the power of the square root is just transform, in this case, c
squared to just c. It also changes 225 into 15. We'll elaborate on square roots
in just a minute.